merci maintenant la parole est à la
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales Nadia sur le groupe
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
chers Sonia notre collègue Sonia de la
provoqué nous propose de mettre en place
un registre national des cancers je ne
suis ni médecin ni chercheur ni
épidémiologiste aussi n'ai-je pas oser
formuler ma première réaction à cette
proposition mais je pensais que c'était
en place depuis longtemps et je suis
certaine que nombre d'entre vous le
pensait également et bien non
aujourd'hui en France les indicateurs de
prévalence d'incidence de mortalité ou
des survie du cancer dont nous disposons
sont des estimations au titre de l'année
2018 extrapoler à partir de 24% de la
population tout d'abord je dois rappeler
que les registres des cancers sont des
outils des recueils de données
individuelles nominatives concrètement
les personnels des registres des
techniciens spécialement formés vont
chercher les informations nécessaires
auprès de différentes sources la
d'anatomie pathologique laboratoire de
biologie établissement de santé publique
et privés assurance maladie réseau de
cancérologie centre régionaux dépistage
du cancer afin d'assurer l'exhaustivité
du repérage des patients il consulte
également les dossiers médicaux dans les
établissements afin de recueillir tous
les items indispensables à la
description du patient et de sa
pathologie la composante humaine de
l'investigation permet la compréhension
du parcours de soins dans sa globalité
de la vie générale des spécialistes que
nous avons auditionnés le travail qui
est fait au niveau du terrain
conditionne la qualité des données
aujourd'hui un parcours de soins est
haché il existe par nature beaucoup de
données de santé chez le général Lee
chez pharmacien à l'hôpital aller
chercher ses données cela suppose des
recherches et cela prend du temps les
registres des cancers ont été créés
progressivement depuis les années 70 il
existe actuellement 19 registres
généraux couvrant 24 départements dont 5
ultramarins 12 registres spécialisés
pour certains types de cancers deux
registres nationaux pour les cancers des
enfants et des adolescents et deux
registres nationaux pour les
mésothéliums pleuraux et les tumeurs
rares du territoire ce sont des outils
très complets dont l'unité
d'enregistrement est l'individu les
modalités de gouvernance et de
financement du système sont cependant
complexes la base commune des registres
qui sont regroupés depuis 95 au sein du
réseau français est hébergé par le
service de biostatistiques des Hospices
Civils de Lyon et gérer conjointement
par l'Institut National du Cancer l'Inca
et santé publique France qui sont aussi
des premiers financeurs de registre à
hauteur des deux tiers alors
souhaitons-nous soutenir dans nos
politiques publiques la montée en
puissance de cet outil potentiellement
très puissant qui permet de mieux
connaître le cancer et donc le combattre
je rappelle que l'on parle de la
première cause de décès chez l'homme et
la deuxième chez la femme si oui il faut
d'abord écouter les opérateurs et
utilisateurs de ces données qui nous
demandent plus de souplesse dans leur
interopérabilité et leur accès d'autres
bases de données telles le système
national des données de santé le snds
regroupant des données de consommation
de soins avec un objectif économique
mais couvrant l'ensemble du territoire
français doivent pouvoir être croisés le
plus simplement possible avec celle des
registres de même par exemple pour les
données de la Caisse Nationale
d'Assurance vieilles que ce soit pour
les expositions environnementales pour
les expositions professionnelles ainsi
que pour les trajectoires de soins le
croisement des bases de données est
indispensable il est actuellement
réalisé de manière probabiliste dans la
majorité des travaux
l'autorisation par voie réglementaire
pour les registres d'utiliser un
identifiant national comme le NIR par
exemple en améliorait grandement la
qualité car les données bien évidemment
sont pseudonymisées soigneusement encodé
ceux qui respectent les exigences du
rgpd mais dans le même temps les
déconnectes du patient et empêchent
d'avoir de lui une vision complète dans
la durée dans le prolongement il
faudrait par voie réglementaire
également autorisé au registre l'accès
aux certificat de décès nominatif et aux
données de mortalité en général il y a
ensuite cette proposition législative
qui consiste à doter la France comme
l’ont fait beaucoup de nos voisins
européens d'un outil harmonisé global et
exhaustif couvrant l'ensemble du
territoire national évidemment cette
construction se fera dans le respect des
outils actuellement en place qui sont
solides et ont fait la preuve de leur
efficacité une forte demande émane du
monde associatif des patients en général
tout autant que de scientifiques et de
responsables administratifs
le rapport de 2017 de Bego polton et von
lennet engagé à constitué des registres
nationaux en cancérologie pour certaines
molécules afin de donner tous leurs
potentiel aux données en vie réelles ce
qui fait toute la différence avec les
recherches sur un échantillon de
patients sélectionnés en 2020 Liga se
relevait en évaluant le troisième plan
cancer que des données à une échelle
géographique plus fine sont nécessaires
en 2021 le Haut Conseil de la santé
publique plaidait pour une meilleure
homogénéisation des données et la
création d'un dispositif national de
détection des signaux faibles l'Académie
de médecine enfin a appelé plus
clairement en 2021 à la création d'un
registre national des cancers accompagné
d'un mécanisme de déclaration
obligatoire de la maladie afin
d'accélérer les remontées d'informations
nécessaires à l'exercice d'une mission
de surveillance sanitaire et l'argile
j'ai été maire d'une commune située à 2
km d'une centrale nucléaire et je vous
confirme la forte demande des
populations pour un maillage territorial
fin permettant une connaissance précise
particulièrement à proximité des sites
sensibles mais aussi des sites pollués
comme les vocales notre collègue
Emmanuel Emilienne pomirol prévenir
plutôt que guérir mais aussi tordre le
cou aux rumeurs évitez les théories du
complot dont on sait comme elle fut vite
et sont difficiles contrôlables si la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui fait suite à de multiples
préconisations y compris scientifiques
il faut dire aussi que certains ont
exprimé des réserves sur la balance coup
efficacité de cette opération je note à
ce sujet d'une façon générale l'extrême
inquiétude du monde de la recherche déjà
entendu lors d'un colloque à l'Académie
de médecine quant à la difficulté
d'accéder au crédit qui leur sont
consacrées souvent dilués dans des
budgets globaux peu lisible difficile à
sanctuariser créer un registre national
des cancers vous ferez également la
possibilité d'inscrire au PLF une ligne
budgétaire dédiée actuellement les
moyens financiers des registres pour la
part qui est versée par l'INCa et santé
publique France sont stables depuis 15
ans alors que le nombre de cancers
augmente on peut comprendre c'est
inquiétude devant la fragilité des
financements qui motive certaines
réserves en particulier celle de
l'inquin mais il serait tellement
dommage que le monde de la recherche
s'autocensure faire le choix de
conserver des données parcellaires alors
qu'il faut une information la plus
précise possible pour planifier l'offre
de soins ce serait payant par ailleurs
difficilement compréhensible certes tout
cela a un coût comme je vous l'exposé en
propos liminaire les opérateurs des
registres passent beaucoup de temps à
rassembler des données on nous a même
dit que les chercheurs eux-mêmes
passaient un temps énorme à saisir des
données voire à chercher des
financements tant qu'il n'est pas
consacré aux travaux de recherche la
généralisation d'une base de données
nationales la mise en commun de
nombreuses informations permettra
optimiser les opérations de saisie et
rendra du temps à la recherche elle
permettra également d’éviter les
doublons et les manquants d'avoir une
veille sanitaire plus large et de régler
le problème du suivi des patients dans
leur mobilité géographique elle
permettra de suivre les cas dans leur
environnement et leur contexte
l'enregistrement systématique en continu
de toutes les données permettra
également de réduire les délais de
production des rapports et n'oublions
pas non plus mes chers collègues que les
données de santé ont un coût mais
également un prix si les industriels ne
trouvent pas en France les données sur
les cancers dont ils ont besoin pour
mettre au point leur traitement ils
iront les acheter ailleurs en Allemagne
qui est en train de se doter d'un
registre national ou en Grande-Bretagne
qui en disposent déjà c'est un vrai
enjeu de compétitivité mondiale et de
souveraineté de la France la recherche
avance chaque jour le niveau de
connaissance de chaque pathologie
s'affine on ne peut plus parler
désormais du cancer mais bien des
cancers que l'on individualise de mieux
en mieux en poussant le raisonnement on
pourrait presque cons montrer que chaque
cancer sera bientôt un cancer rare d'où
l'intérêt des Cortes les plus larges
possible international ou au moins
européennes qui seront forcément plus
pertinentes que les extrapolations ou
les échantillons après que le Plan
Cancer est créé en France l'Institut
National du Cancer l'Inca qui est un
modèle envié il y a une vraie logique à
mettre désormais entre ses mains un
registre national des cancers qui
concentrera des données fiables
exploitables et surtout extrêmement
utile tout cela a du sens alors mes
chers collègues au moment de faire un
vote qui sera observé et qui est un
signe fort nous savons ce que nous
attendons d'un registre national des
cancers il doit nous aider à sauver le
plus de vie possible alors donnons-lui
les moyens de le faire je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre vous avez la parole